Good afternoon and welcome to toxic Google in Cambridge,
Massachusetts.
Today it's my privilege to introduce two extraordinary individuals,
professor Lani Guinier and Dr Deborah Beal.
Among many other things,
both are fierce advocates of equal educational opportunity for all.
Debra Beal was MacArthur fellow in 2007 she has an education strategist who
addresses the challenges of college access for underrepresented populations by
identifying and fostering latent talent and opening opportunities for them to
pursue higher education through her posse foundation,
which is a funded in part by Google.
She offers an alternative model for identifying promising young people from less
advantage urban environments.
Promising students are invited to join a Posse,
a small group that participates in an eight month pre-collegiate training
program that builds individual and team skills and serves as an essential social
support system once students arrive at college.
She served as the founder and president of the foundation posse foundation since
1989 she is also a founding partner of the consulting company Firefly Education
Llc.
Lani Guinier is the first woman of color appointed to a tenured professorship at
Harvard law school.
Previously.
She had been a tenured professor at the University of Pennsylvania,
a lawyer with the Naacp Legal Defense Fund,
special assistant to the assistant attorney general for civil rights during the
Carter Administration and was nominated by President Clinton to be the first
black woman to have the civil rights division of the Department of Justice.
Uh,
professor Guinier on behalf of the people of the United States.
I apologize for how that went.
Sincerely,
uh,
she is the author of several books,
most recently the tyranny of the meritocracy,
democratizing higher education in America,
and she has received 10 honorary degrees,
although I suspect that she feels equally honored to have received awards for
teaching excellence from both Penn and Harvard law.
School's please join me in welcoming in conversation.
Lani Guinier and Deborah veal.
We're just winging this.
You guys.
Not really,
we're acting like we are,
but to,
I'm Debbie bial.
I run the posse foundation and I'm Lani Guinier and I'm
a law professor who
is very fond of the posse.
We're fond of each other.
We really are.
Actually I admire Lani enormously and one of the,
this is the first time that we are,
we've actually come together to talk about an issue that we've been dealing with
separately for decades.
And what I am so grateful to Lani for is that she has written extensively about
an issue that this country doesn't talk enough about.
And that is the idea that the country was built on,
which is there were supposed to be a meritocracy.
And she,
I work a lot.
I work with 52 different colleges and universities,
all elite.
And those institutions are really gatekeepers for young people who want to
achieve the American dream.
And Lonnie has written a lot about that.
And you've,
you give,
you validate what we do at posse and I'll talk more about that.
That I,
I wanted to thank you because it's an honor to be here.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
So I'll just be quiet and I'll let you talk.
No,
it's a privilege to be here.
I've had,
um,
a lot of opportunity to talk to and,
work with one of the form of posse officers,
surely Co Yaddo.
Right.
And she was a posse member,
right?
Yeah.
Right.
And she's the one who really explained to me what it was like to be a posse
member.
And
Her story is so powerful because she's the son of the son.
She's the daughter of a taxi driver who was somebody who would come to the
United States from another country.
And her father was extremely worried that she was going to leave New York City
to go to Vanderbilt,
which is in Tennessee.
And so they arranged an agreement that she would call him or he would call her
every day.
He's a taxi driver at nine o'clock or at eight o'clock.
And she'd have to report to him as to what she was doing.
And it turned out initially that she thought this was,
um,
intrusive,
but it turned out to be very,
um,
powerful in a way of reassuring her cause she was in a new environment
completely without,
um,
you know,
coming in with old friends or,
or with people who've been there before.
And so the fact that she had somebody to look forward to,
to talk to every night was,
um,
very affirming for her.
She ended up doing extraordinarily well.
She ended up getting a phd.
She's now,
um,
uh,
I'm not sure exactly her she decision at Rutgers,
but she's no high predicative vice chancellor.
Yeah.
Okay.
Executive Vice Chancellor.
Who used to rely on her taxi cab father to move on to the next day of,
of her life.
So she,
she's,
she's just a really good example of,
um,
the posse program.
But
Lonnie rights,
I don't know how you guys should all read her book.
She,
which we have,
and there's kind of make the pitch at the beginning of the middle men,
but Lonnie has a whole chapter dedicated to this program as an example of how we
can be thinking differently about defining this term merit.
And I like to talk about the word merit because I don't know how many of you
went to one of,
you know,
what we call the most selective colleges in the United States,
but there's over 1400,
four year colleges in the United States.
If you took just the top 10% right.
The ones that everyone's heard about,
the Ivy League schools and Vanderbilt,
Northwestern and Duke and these kinds of schools Middleburry,
they still rely pretty heavily on the sat as a way of deciding who's,
who's going to be admitted.
Right.
You're familiar,
you know,
you know this idea,
but in 2015 it's still white and Asian kids that are scoring the best on those
tests.
Now we can talk about all the problems and why that is the case,
but here's a kid like Shirley and I just want to jump on your story a little
bit.
Surely grew up in Brooklyn.
She's a Dominican kid who got 800 combined.
I'm letting this thinking combined on the math and reading sections of the sat.
She lets us say this combined.
She never in a million years would've gotten into Vanderbilt.
We get her into Vanderbilt.
She graduates with honors.
She gets her doctorate in clinical psychology from Duke.
She becomes the dean of the college at Middlebury and within the next five
years,
I think she's going to be a college president today.
Those schools that I mentioned,
88% of the presidents of those schools are white men.
If you look at who's in the U S Senate,
94% of our Senate is white.
Most are men.
The same thing with who runs fortune 500 companies,
white guys mostly,
and their section 16 executives white.
So what we're talking about is,
well,
how do we keep going like that,
right,
Lonnie?
Because if we keep doing that in a country where the demographics are changing
radically,
and what within the next 30 years is white,
Hispanics will be the minority.
No longer be the majority.
We're not going to have a country that's representative of its people.
So maybe we could talk a little bit about how these institute,
why it's important for the elite schools.
Why do you think
and why do I,
why should they be focused on thinking differently about who deserves to be on
their campuses?
So just to put what you're saying into a slightly larger,
um,
context,
and I've,
I definitely want to follow up with your saying is the book that,
that I'm
describing or that actually you've done a great job of describing is,
is really about what we mean by merit.
And so it's,
it's a larger question than just,
uh,
who is benefiting from the concept of merit.
But we tend to think of merit as something that measures how well you do on a
particular test.
That a particular moment and what I am trying to do in this book and what I
think is consistent with what the posse program does,
is to give people another way of identifying with an exhibiting merit.
And that is working together in groups in posses that can look at a problem from
different perspectives and as a result work together to solve that problem.
And adding to your comment about the number of,
um,
of,
of men versus women and finding more women in,
um,
in who are going to college and who and who are graduating.
Because it turns out that the women are better at collaborating with each other
than the men.
There's a study by a woman named Anita Woolley who
in fact I think was working with MIT at at the same time she was doing this
study and what they were trying to find out is who was leading the conversation
and what groups were most effective in solving the particular problems that were
presented before the groups.
And it turned out that the more women you had in the group,
the better the group was at solving the problem up to 85% once you had 85%
women,
it was fine to bring in the men.
They would not be a complete distraction.
Okay.
Now why would that be if,
if we have so few women who are in positions of power and yet those are the
people who are most likely to work together to collaborate,
to solve problems.
And I don't know the answer to the question of why is this true of women and not
men.
It may be biological,
it may be cultural.
They're all kinds of explanations.
But it's really important that we acknowledge the value and the merit of people.
Disproportionately women who can work together to solve problems.
And the reason they can work together to solve problems is that they're willing
to listen to each other.
Whereas what many of the men do is that they immediately think of an answer.
I want to say the answer to everyone else.
They're not really interested in what other people are saying.
They're self promoting it.
Not Not all men,
but,
but many of them.
And so it,
the point I'm trying to make the point I'm emphasizing is the power of
collaboration and the importance in the 21st century of developing a,
um,
a group of college graduates who are comfortable working with other people to
solve complicated problems and who are not simply trying to dominate the
conversation and demonstrate the how smart they individually are,
but who are willing to listen to what other people are saying.
Build on what those other people are saying and create new and,
um,
helpful instruments for solving these problems.
One last example is a professor from the University of Michigan who
also is,
is doing work on,
um,
on groups and,
and his experience is with people who are all taking the same test.
And his argument is that when you give people a test in their 10 questions on
the test,
there are some people who are going to immediately answer seven of the 10
questions and get them right,
but they don't get all of the questions right.
So what does,
what do they do?
Our instinct is to get the people who had the seven of the 10 questions,
right?
Cause they had the most questions,
And we put all of them together.
That's the sort of sat idea.
You get the people who all did quote the best.
But what if it turns out that you're overlooking two or three of the answers to
questions that these quote unquote stars got wrong.
And that some people got those three or two questions right?
Me,
but didn't get as many questions.
Right?
As,
as the initial,
um,
group leaders that you really want people to work together.
Even those,
they only got two or three of the 10 questions,
right.
If it turns out that they're the only ones who got those,
um,
correct.
So the idea is that,
and I think it's very similar and very compatible with the concept of Posse,
is that you have to,
in the 21st century,
it's really important that you can work in groups that you can,
and I don't mean that work in groups in your march together and you follow
everyone.
I mean,
work in a puzzle,
in a position where you are not the only person with ideas.
You are open to other people's ideas and you're willing to test out their ideas
and,
and see ways in which those ideas can be improved or can be.
Um,
that's very Google,
very Google.
But Lonnie,
can I ask why since I have you captive anyway,
why do you think we've been so resistant
to to this at our,
when we admit people to these colleges,
why are we,
why are we clinging to the sat so much?
Well,
first of all,
there's a lot of money.
Yeah,
yeah.
Behind the sat and,
and,
and those tests.
So th there's a part of the population that's invested in,
in that,
in terms of their livelihood.
I think it's,
um,
the idea that you can reduce people's intelligence and you can reduce people's
ability to the performance.
Yeah.
On,
on a single test.
Right.
It's not like you get a chance to,
to do this test.
Yeah.
You know,
every month for a year,
raise your hand if you took the sat or the act.
Look,
how many of you,
almost all of you,
and raise your hand if you raise your hand if you went to college
and raise your hand.
Raise your hand if someone said to you,
what,
what was your score?
Do you remember that?
It's an raise your hand if you're willing to tell us your score right now.
Exactly.
A lot less hands because we still feel like it reflects,
there's a judgment that we're going to make about you.
If we hear score,
that's,
that's terrible.
We shouldn't make that judgment about you right now.
And look how old you are.
It's what we,
can I just,
can I just hang a footnote to what you're saying and then,
yeah,
no,
I'm,
yes.
No,
sir.
To tell you it's a personal story.
When I was admitted to
Radcliffe College of hotel,
this is a good story
in your,
in your end.
Yeah.
I love the story.
So,
um,
uh,
my father had,
my father who had,
was born in Jamaica,
west indies.
He came to the United States,
he went to Boston,
English high school.
He then applied to Harvard.
He was admitted to Harvard College,
except that they didn't realize he was black.
He,
right,
they didn't,
they didn't have that kind of photography or whatever,
no photos.
That was,
and that was his mistake,
a quote unquote,
because he showed up and once they saw him,
they said,
oh my God,
what are we going to do with you?
So,
um,
they admitted him since they had already admitted him,
but they wouldn't allow him to live in the dormitory.
They wouldn't allow him to,
um,
to eat in the dining halls with the other students.
And the first person to,
um,
well there are a number of people,
but
the people he knew from Boston English high school where he had been the chair
of the,
um,
newspaper and had done very well and who were his friends?
Those people were very friendly when he was at Boston English high.
But once he was at Harvard College,
they wouldn't talk to him either.
So
I'm saying that because for me,
he felt it was important that I go to Harvard,
right.
Test it out,
see if they've improved in the past
40 years.
But it was also,
it was also in many ways this,
um,
what I felt was a painful experience.
That is my,
uh,
roommate.
I believe that's what you're talking about.
So my roommate comes into my
dorm room the first day of class and she starts telling me about herself and she
explained that she was very worried that she would never get married.
And I'm thinking this is a very odd conversation,
right?
This is the first day of college.
You know,
I'm 17 years old.
I have definitely not thinking about who I might marry.
But,
um,
she was using this as an opportunity to brag about her test scores because it
turns out she had gotten perfect eight hundreds on her sats.
So that was,
um,
her announcement to me and I was there for,
you know,
a pen I should be observant of her and learn from her.
And what I learned was to move to another dorm room.
But what did,
what did she mean
and what other people would be really impressed is that she's smart.
We equate that test score with intelligence and when we use the word merit in
Higher Ed and we give out merit scholarships,
we give them to the kids with the highest test scores.
Because if you look the word up in the dictionary,
it means deserve.
Who deserves to be at Harvard?
Who deserves to be at Cornell,
who deserves to be at Vanderbilt,
the kids with the highest scores because they are the smartest.
It's that simple.
But because white and Asian kids are still scoring the best,
they deserve to be at the schools more than black and Asian kids than poor kids
who don't score as well.
There's an amazing stat that I know you're gonna love this stat.
Okay?
The top hundred and 50 schools in the United States would need 50,000 black
students every year going into their freshman class,
their first year class,
if they were going to reflect the percentage of blacks that exists in the
American population,
but only 9,000 black kids score 1200 or above on the math and verbal sections of
the sat last year in the entire United States.
If we continue to rely too heavily on the sat,
will never get the kind of reflective diversity that we want on our campuses.
And if we continue to define merit so narrowly that it only relates to the test
score,
we're basically gonna say certain kinds.
There are certain slice of the demographic deserves to be on our campuses.
The others will create charity programs for at risk,
poor kids,
underrepresented,
needy,
you know,
underprivileged.
We've got programs for them.
And when you do that,
you divide the community,
you create a campus community that says these kids deserve to be here,
and then out of the kindness of our hearts,
we're bringing in the rest of you.
And that's very dangerous for this country.
Kids with high scores of course,
are deserve of course,
but they're not the only kids that deserve.
And so I feel like what we have an opportunity to do together is say,
here's the theory and the analysis behind it and here's one example of a program
that puts into practice this other way of finding talent and think about how
Google is a company that thinks outside the box that you're whole.
You're all about that,
right?
You need people who are creative thinkers who think differently and the,
and you want to put teams together.
Right.
Do you guys believe in working in teams a lot or is that just what I'm imagining
you do?
Right.
The teens are more fun.
They're more dynamic there,
sillier,
but the you come up with great ideas that way where if you're working by
yourself only it would happen in a different way.
Less often.
So posse says there was a kid who dropped out of college.
He said,
I never would've dropped out if I had my posse with me.
This kid was super smart,
great sat scores by the way,
got into an ivy league but dropped out because of the culture shock cause it,
he didn't see anybody like him.
The posse created a support system.
But then we began to look at these other indicators.
And I bet if anybody,
is anyone here responsible for hiring people?
What's her name?
Ryan.
Brian.
Brian W.
So you don't only care about a test score,
now you look for other things.
You look for Grit,
you look for leadership ability.
You look for,
um,
analytical ability,
problem solving skills,
ability to work well in a team,
collaborate like I can go on and on.
Right?
Aren't you looking for all those things?
Yes.
So among,
I'm not saying the whole of when these kids are 17 years old,
they're nominated to posse and we,
I wish I could stand up.
I always want to stand up,
but we can put them in a room like no,
because the camera and the,
Oh,
the whole thing.
But imagine a room like this with no furniture and a hundred kids from Boston
come into this room.
They'd been nominated by someone who believes in them.
And the person who believes in them says this kid might not have the best score,
but I know her.
She's amazing.
She could kick ass at a school like union.
They walk in and for three hours,
and,
and Brian,
I think you would love this if we did it at Google.
Those hundred kids get put through a series of activities.
They're building robots out of Legos.
They're running a discussion in small groups on genetic testing.
Quick.
You have four minutes running discussion.
They're creating a public service announcement that they have to present in
front of you.
And we're watching them and looking for these,
what I don't like this term,
but people call noncognitive traits,
their cognitive,
but I'm just anyway.
And we find the standout kids,
the dynamic kids,
the kids who think creatively,
the kids who are work well in teams,
the kids who are leaders who have ambition and drive and motivation and all of
that.
That's our first slice of the pie.
Not just,
we don't even look at the test score yet.
We'll look at that later.
That's one way of finding talent.
Kids who are amazing kids who deserve to have a shot at the American dream.
And so we're putting into practice this idea that you shouldn't define merit so
narrowly.
No,
I think that's a great example.
I'm also thinking
of some of the TV shows where you can see,
um,
black kids walking across the,
the terrain in front of the projects.
And in,
in one of these shows that there were two brothers who were talking about the
amount of marijuana that they had each,
um,
sold that that particular day and how much money they had made.
And the younger one was computing in his head how you know,
how,
how much she had sold and how much he had benefited from the sale.
And his older brother was just amazed because the,
the younger brother who was in the fourth grade or fifth grade,
it was not doing well in math and yet he's doing this in his head.
And so the older brother says,
well,
how come you're,
you're failing math?
And he said,
because,
um,
I don't really care what the outcome is and Meth,
but I care in terms of selling these drugs that if I get it wrong,
they're going to kill me.
So there's a talent there but it's not being done in the right format.
[inaudible] so we have like a few more minutes to talk and then we're going to
open it up for questions.
And I thought maybe it would also be interesting to hear a little bit more about
how you think these higher ed institutions can change what you think they can
do.
Well,
this is an opportunity for me to cry because I've been trying to get
institutions where I teach two at address.
They don't necessarily have to cure,
but at least addressed the issues that we've been discussing.
Now I've been at law schools,
not at elementary schools or at quote unquote colleges.
But what I did find,
and this is not about,
um,
class as much as it is about gender,
the people at,
um,
both law schools that I was associated or have been associated with,
both at U Penn,
at Harvard,
um,
there are more men than women in the school.
The men outperform the women,
although the women come into the school with very similar criteria as the men in
terms of their Lsa t scores and their undergraduate GPA.
In fact,
the women have slightly higher undergraduate GPA and have slightly higher Lsa t
scores,
but they're statistically not significant.
And yet the women,
when they come to law school,
these are
considered important and difficult to get into law schools.
The women have the Lsa t scores that that would presumably predicted they're
going to do better in law school,
but they don't do as well as the men in law school.
So the Lsa Lsit is predicting about 14% of the variance in first year classes.
This was at Penn and 15% of the variance in second year,
which means that 85% of the time the Lsa t was wrong.
Raw,
So what,
what's showing on the Lsit is not a good predictor.
It,
it,
it tells you how well somebody is at,
at answering certain questions under a lot of stress.
But,
but that doesn't mean you're going to be a good lawyer and it doesn't mean
you're going to be a good a law student either.
So if 85% of the time you are wrong in terms of the correlation between your Lsa
t scores and your performance,
your performance,
we need to reconsider what we're considering quote unquote merit.
And so what's,
uh,
what should they do?
If you could press the button and Harvard and Yale and Princeton would change,
how would they change?
Well,
the answer to that is a long one because it has,
they'd have to change the culture.
It's not enough just to change the score because you could say,
oh well they can check.
They,
they could say if you pass the Lsit,
that's enough.
You don't have to have a higher LSAP.
Since the distinction in your Lsa t score,
he really is not very predictive.
So I mean that,
so the lsit could be a floor that is,
you have to get above that floor.
Even if you write above it,
that's fine.
We're not going to compare you to people who are,
um,
doing a lot better.
Cause that,
I mean,
I could show you scatter,
et cetera.
We,
you see people who had really high LSA t scores and really low,
um,
law school grades.
I mean,
my guests,
Lonnie,
is that people listening to you?
I have this sense,
no,
or wondering if maybe those scores would be more predictive.
If culture was different on these campuses that I as a woman,
I get a high score and I go to Harvard.
But because the culture is a certain way,
my performance is effected,
but I don't know.
Um,
but this is true for men and women in terms of the El set.
Oh,
it is good predictor of performance.
So,
so then,
so becoming a man is not going to help you in terms of doing better at,
um,
at law schools.
But what I really wanted to get back to,
which is what posse is
well known for is the power of working with other people,
collaborating and building trust among that group of people,
each of whom is bringing something new,
something different,
something,
um,
potentially important too to the group.
And so the challenges,
are you in a position to take advantage of what the various people in this room
or in,
in,
in a particular group have to offer?
Or are you one of these people who has to dominate the conversation,
has to show how smart you are and has to take charge in which you're leading and
everyone is just following that could be very boring.
Whereas if and and also not very effective.
Whereas if we had a culture shift,
not just a rule shift,
meaning I cultureship that says what the way we think merit and uh,
Amartya Sen has a definition of merit,
merit.
It is an incentive system that rewards actions,
a society values and incentive system that rewards actions,
the society values.
Well,
what are the maybe the actions that we value or not how well you do on the test,
but how well you're doing stopping the real problems of the world and that you
alone are not going to be able to do that.
But if you find the right posse,
you find the right group of people,
each of whom has something to offer,
then you're in a position to start really solving difficult problems.
And it's not that you alone are going to solve them.
And it may not be that even the group you're part of alone is gonna solve the
problem,
but you're introducing interventions that,
um,
in invite and excite other people who then build on what you've done.
And through that process,
I think we'll be in much,
much better shape.
By contrast,
what we have right now,
at least in college admission and college graduation is competition as to who
have chosen us,
who's doing the best that is whose school is,
um,
admitting the students with the highest El sat scores and then whose schools are
graduating the people who go and make the most money.
And then the idea of the contribution to society,
the,
the commitment to democracy,
the commitment to,
um,
making sure that as a democracy we want to make sure everybody as many people as
possible are educated because we never know among those people who's going to
really contribute something unique and something that's brave and something
that,
that really works.
We don't have a good predictor of,
of that outcome through the Lsit,
the sat,
the GRE,
none of those.
What those,
um,
tests tend to tell us is what kind of car your parents drive.
Meaning they co right?
They have enough money to buy a Mercedes.
So you've obviously been able to do well on this test because they've also
bought people who are going to help you to get prepared for the test.
And then of course,
when you're writing out your,
um,
admissions data,
you also get somebody else who writes it for you.
And right there,
there are,
they're working on your behalf presumably,
but they're not going to be there when you're in college and you have an exam or
something else to do that you're really not prepared for because the way you got
there was somebody else was pushing you or function as a pedestal on which you
could stand.
So,
so I'm saying all this because I think that the posse program is wonderful,
not just because it's bringing together students from working class families,
but because it's also giving us the opportunity to see how teams can be created
and,
um,
and built in ways that not only give people who are part of the team confidence,
but give the people who benefit from the outcome of the work of the team.
Uh,
some sense that life is better with the interventions.
I'm going to use that as a quote in our next [inaudible] Ken,
it was good.
So should we,
yes.
Turn to you guys because you have a million questions.
I'm sure.
I hope not a million,
but um,
starting at the beginning.
Okay.
So it sounds like the population that you're most concerned with are the
students that are both minorities and talented.
And I guess I have,
my brother is now applying to colleges.
He's just deciding where he's going.
So,
um,
I've been kind of like hearing a lot about this lately and I have questions
about the population who is either
like some talented but not diverse,
you know,
not minority and the population that is that is maybe not so talented.
So I guess my,
my two kinds of situations are that I,
that I've seen that are kind of like concerning one is say a friend of mine
who's White Guy,
you know,
in engineering really smart and like is really struggling to get into schools.
He kick feels like that,
you know,
there are a lot of spots that are reserved for people of other categories and
like he's really smart white guy and it's just like really struggling to kind of
like get noticed because he doesn't have anything,
anything special.
And in this,
in this particular case,
he gets his parents went to college,
community college,
not really super academic kind of people like you really didn't have,
he wasn't from,
you know,
like a Mercedes driving kind of family.
Didn't really get the,
like the,
the support and the motivation and everything.
But he feels like,
because you know,
he's white doesn't really count for anything.
So that's kind of like the one situation of like talented but not minority.
And the other situation that I see are people who are really not interested in
pursuing academic careers.
Their intro,
you know,
I actually was a serious ballet dancer and a lot of my friends didn't go to
college because if you want to be a valid answer,
why would you spend $160,000 on a college education?
It doesn't make any sense or more,
um,
more.
Yeah.
So,
so what about for those people who want to,
or they want to pursue culinary arts?
So they want to do whatever else that doesn't,
shouldn't require.
It doesn't depend on getting your college education where they feel like they're
being pressured to spend a fortune.
And go into debt to get an education that maybe,
maybe they could have an excellent professional career doing the things that
they want with another path that somehow looked down upon.
So I guess what are your thoughts on,
on people in those two situations?
Either way.
Yeah,
go ahead.
So
first I think you should go to Canada.
You don't have to stay,
just visit and see the way in which they admit people to their schools.
You have a grade point average of over 80%.
You're automatically admitted to one of their,
um,
colleges.
And I don't know that you're entitled to your first choice,
but they try and give you at least one of your first three choices.
And I don't,
um,
I don't believe college is free,
but it's not very expensive.
So if that would solve a lot of the problems that,
that,
that you're talking about,
the other point that you're making though,
I think is really important and that is that people are coming to college and
they're really not there to learn.
They're there to promote themselves into another sphere where there'll be making
a lot of money.
So,
for example,
in the Harvard Crimson of about five
or so years ago,
they had an article called show him the money that was the front page of the
Harvard Crimson.
That's the newspaper,
the students and what they were commenting on.
And they had done a survey of the graduating class.
This was in May of that year.
And the survey noted that the men from Harvard wanted to go to Wall Street
because they want it to make a lot of money.
And the women wanted to become lawyers or,
or doctors or teachers.
And the people who were writing this article were making fun of the women,
the women who wanted to do good because they should have been trying to get the
money.
And it suggests that,
that's why I say you need a culture shift.
It's not just the,
that you have a certain group of people and not another group of people.
It's that the culture of higher education has lost some of its connection to the
Di,
the promoting democracy and the importance of civic involvement.
That is the basis of um,
of,
of many of the colleges in,
in,
in this country.
It's,
it's the reason that they were created and yet they've,
they've been shifted from an engine of democracy to an engine of plutocracy
and Monica,
I think there,
can you help me answer this also there's,
I have an idea formulation.
They,
because behind what you're saying is a question that I've heard a lot of times
from
white people whose kids are applying to college and they're worried that the
black kid is going to take the spot that their kid should get.
And I'm not saying this is your question,
but I hear it kind of and I sh I hear that question a lot.
There's a black kid in my daughter's school and she didn't score as well as my
daughter did on the sat and I know she's going to get in to x school and my
daughter deserves to be at that school and there is resentment that builds.
How do you,
how are you supposed to think about that?
How does the country think about that?
It is very difficult for us to understand that the numbers of black kids going
to these elite institutions is very small and 10 extra or 20 extra kids that get
inserted into that freshman class,
even if they didn't have the test score is not the effect it has on the number
of white students applying in.
Their chances of getting in is minuscule,
but it feels big because we all know of a black kid who gets in with a lower
score.
It's this problem of using the score to define deserving anyone in this room and
listening and online and all of that.
Who thinks that admissions
is,
this is an objective process is wrong.
It's completely subjective.
The Dean of admission says,
we need a violinist.
Let's try and find a great violinist for our orchestra.
We this year we need more kids who want a major in our new curriculum in
communications.
It's just about building a class,
but we're so competitive and we,
we compete against our friends and our kids friends and our parents rent.
All of this stuff that we end up resenting.
The black kid who got in with the lower score.
It's a big problem and I don't know how to articulate it more,
but yeah,
no,
I think you've articulated it very effectively.
The question is what's the intervention?
What like how do we change our mindset almost doubled.
I think we have to go back to,
um,
understanding what's the purpose of higher education and it's not there simply
to give your child or my child an opportunity to make a lot of money.
Right?
It's also a very important engine of democracy and that's the part of the Co,
the college that we don't really talk about that we want students who are going
to graduate from college and make a contribution to our society that promotes
democracy.
That by democracy I don't mean,
I mean fairness.
I mean,
um,
engagement of the citizen re in making decisions that affect their lives in our
lives.
That we're not,
that college is not just a platform for,
um,
becoming a millionaire or becoming,
continuing in your,
your parents footsteps and being a person.
Yeah.
Great.
Great way of framing it.
Thank you.
Are you okay with somewhat more of a comment than a question?
No,
absolutely not.
You need to sit down.
No,
just kidding.
Just kidding.
I see the essence of,
of what you were saying as as three areas.
One is scoring people based on some perceived stability being done badly and the
alternative is,
is over credentialism you have a degree,
therefore you must be qualified to do an entire class of work unrelated to the
degree.
Um,
there is the diversity aspect where,
um,
you're clearly losing the game if you're not getting included in,
in the solution,
um,
and someone else's disproportionately winning the game.
But my pet peeve is the,
the posse versus singular,
um,
uh,
model of it.
Survival of the fittest
is universally accepted as the driver of evolution.
That if you have someone who keeps his tribal live by sacrificing himself or
herself,
then then I'm,
that person's genes aren't being carried down directly and therefore,
clearly that person was a failure.
But if you look at how evolution actually works,
the tribe's succeeds.
The tribe survives because one person was willing to sacrifice for the group's
success.
And that strikes me as an almost direct,
um,
uh,
very,
it's very much of the issue of you have five people were very good each at one
science and none of them can get along.
You add a sixth person who gets people along with each other and finally the
team can succeed rather than being a bunch of individuals.
Even for leadership,
which is one of the aspects we consider in recruitment.
It is hierarchical sort of leadership.
We look at it is not management of a group to make the group effective.
It is domination of the group in order to make the group do what it's told.
And I feel like that is not just some people are winning and are there,
people are losing.
But our consensus as a society seems to be on the wrong rules of the wrong rules
of physics,
you might say about how these things work.
And I feel like that is an understanding that needs to be spread.
And I'm glad you're doing it.
Oh,
well I'm glad you just came up and made what I thought was a very powerful
argument.
So thank you.
So,
uh,
I have just enough personal experience,
not nearly as much as either or both of yours to beat dangerous sadness,
meaning I had a daughter who went through the process this year and I'm a
regional enrollment director from my Amada.
Okay.
So I see a lot of really scary numbers and things experiences happen from both
the applicant perspective and the alumni perspective.
So my view is the entire process is of getting into colleges and going through
colleges.
It's completely broken for everybody,
regardless of what your socioeconomic,
racial,
gender classes,
it's a hundred percent broken for everybody.
And somebody has to do something drastic soon to take a leadership role and
changing it.
But because institutions exist to continue to exist,
it's happening way too slowly.
So I going to tell you an idea I sent to my,
our admissions director at our campus this spring that I think after his,
you know,
eyes and ears got done bleeding after he read the idea,
he sent me a politically correct no back.
Okay.
But my,
my idea was because there's all the,
all these colleges are keeping score on an yeah.
Rankings,
number of applications yields accepted it.
There's all kinds of scorecards.
I said,
my recommendation is next year we have no applications.
There is no application process.
The process is,
well not exactly.
You take your admissions officers who spend time reading too many applications
and delivering on the admission directors need for the communications class with
a violinist and they just go out into the community and they find your,
they find it right.
1200 people for it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Why don't we do that?
Someone's got to be first.
Yeah,
and so my question for you is,
is anybody close to being first with anything that matters in this?
I mean,
the closest thing I see to this is maybe what's happening in technology with Ed
acts and things like that,
but they are still premium institutions and they haven't figured out how to
commercialize it,
but it's anybody doing anything material to be first at this and start to change
it.
I mean,
I have some,
yes.
Some things.
I love what you're saying because you're saying we have to be radical,
right?
It's not enough.
This little small,
you know Lonnie,
who's a civil rights expert and witnessed the progress we made his,
his all to witnessing as we all are,
how how we are moving backwards.
We striked down the voting rights act and we lose affirmative action and we
think because we're there,
we've solved the problem.
We have a black president done but so we need to be more radical because we move
away too slowly.
As you're saying,
so what you know moocs have evolved.
Higher Ed is going to change the,
there's,
we call it sometimes the,
the higher ed bubble.
Remember we had these,
these other technology bubbles and stuff,
but it's going to burst.
People will not be able to afford this kind of higher education within the next,
I don't know how many years.
The schools can't afford it.
We can't afford it.
Something's going to change.
I just wanted to mention this is not supposed to be about posse.
I wanted to mention that this year we had 15,000 nominations from all over the
United States for 700 slots and every one of those 15,000 kids came from someone
who said,
this is a great kid.
He should be going to this great school.
Someone who believes in this kid knows this kid.
Frankly,
in my opinion,
all 15,000 of those kids should be sent to these great schools.
Nothing would happen that's bad.
It would only be good,
but those 15,000 kids came into a room that was radically different.
It wasn't about scores and grades and tests.
It was about all of these other qualities that we think could make a great
student on a campus and a great leader in the workforce.
If we could do more of that,
replicate these large group interviews,
these large group opportunities for companies like Google to hire for schools
like Vanderbilt to admit students for whatever it is that we're looking for.
It gives us another way of finding talent that's more radical because it's not
just sitting in a room and looking at a piece of paper and making a decision.
I know we are,
we're running out of time because it's with three minutes.
But I love that.
And there are things that are happening and I just think we need to keep pushing
it really loudly that,
that we should,
we should radically change the system or it'll just break like you said,
and then we will have no choice.
We cannot end on that note.
So please ask them.
I'll be real fast cause of time.
Um,
meritocracy rests on a bedrock of scarcity.
We can only enlist x many people each year.
So how do we pick,
and you make good points about changing the metric,
but you also mentioned if I change the metric than some other people who
might've otherwise deserve don't get to go.
The other way to approach that problem is to drastically increase the number of
people who are able to go.
So what are your thoughts about changing that restriction of the small number of
people who are kind of able to go to college?
That's positive.
Yeah,
I agree with you.
Yeah.
Moocs might be able to make that happen.
You know,
we may be able to create more systems that take more kids,
go to Canada and see what they do.
That again,
this is,
nope,
I'm bring,
because if you have 80% or above,
um,
in,
in terms of your,
uh,
high school grades,
you're entitled to go to college in Canada.
They've figured that out.
Yup.
Right?
My kids are not Canadian.
All right.
I have a nine year old and a six year old and nine months I've done.
I'm glad they're not getting into college at this age.
I have to start financially planning for that now because it's going to cost me
half a million dollars to send them and I,
how do we solve that problem?
Right.
You know what I mean?
But that's part of what I'm seeing.
Literacy is so important that we give it away for free.
Five Sec.
Go to Canada.
And you know what?
I think what you're hearing is that we can,
but it's not an answerable question right now.
You're right.
We need everybody to feel like the opportunity to reach an American dream.
Whatever that dream is,
exists.
And it feels unbelievably unfair,
right?
We're living in a country that has 33% of its population living in poverty or
what we call near poverty,
33% those kids,
we don't even talk about them.
Do you read about the poverty that exists in United States?
You don't really.
And so we need to talk about it.
The middle class has gotten squeezed out of education because the cost is so
enormous.
So we end up with schools that we called rich poor schools.
The rich kids can go and the really poor kids can get these scholarships.
It's not enough.
And we need to find a way to make state systems work for everybody to make great
schools expand what they offer to more people.
And we haven't figured it out.
You're right.
We have to figure it out.
And maybe by the time your kids are older,
there'll be something great but okay.
But it's not just an,
and I think what you just said is great,
but it's not as too negative.
No,
no,
no.
But it's something that we,
yeah,
we don't have the capacity to solve that problem alone.
But it's,
it's an issue that that's why I keep talking about Canada.
You should go to Finland or to other countries and see that in these other
countries they are committed to making sure every student to use them as models.
Yeah.
Something we could copy.
Right.
If we think we are
in a position of greatness,
we need to go and actually see greatness that is democratic as opposed to
plutocratic as what,
which is what we have here.
So we said the test scores are not predictive of of college success,
but you have this posse selection process.
Is that,
is that predictive?
Yeah,
so I didn't say they're not predictive.
Test scores are limited.
They predict for some kids and the only thing the sats predict is how well
you're going to do your first year in college,
what your GPA will be and it doesn't PR again,
it's like Loni said,
it's incredibly flood,
but it finds some great kids.
Posse kids graduated rates of over 90% from 52 colleges and universities that we
send them to thousands of posse kids have one $800 million in scholarships over
the past 25 years.
So we've got a program that's showing that what Lonnie's talking about totally
works,
right?
We've got thousands of kids in an experiment,
and this other way of identifying talent is just as good as the sat.
All I'm saying is we can't just only use the sat.
We need many more ways of finding great kids,
and then the cost is another issue.
Yeah.
Okay.
You guys,
thank you so much,
Lani.
A pleasure to be with you.
Thank you everybody.